y les pregunto a ustedes de qué sirve
que un niño pueda ordenar correctamente
los planetas en el sistema solar si
cuando está triste no sabe qué hacer si
cuando está con rabia no sabe cómo
descargarla
sin duda todos alguna vez aquí pensamos
que el mundo cada día sería mejor al pse
en la mano los que creen que el mundo
cada día será mejor a ver yo lo he
pensado
muy bien veamos veamos
contaminamos el planeta con mucha
facilidad y sin remordimientos la
inseguridad está pero a todo nivel la
corrupción la injusticia y podríamos
seguir toda la noche en él estando un
sinnúmero de situaciones entonces hoy en
día la educación realmente debe
enfocarse en darnos aquellas
herramientas que nos van a permitir
vivir en un planeta bajo presión y salir
victoriosos de aquello por eso es
indispensable que en esta cuarta
revolución que es la tecnológica la
educación tenga como objetivo y perfil
de salida a una persona inteligente
emocionalmente para ellos quienes somos
educadores debemos utilizar el contenido
solamente como un medio para lograr
desarrollar competencias y habilidades
emocionales en los estudiantes
ciertamente los maestros no podemos
parar el cambio esto se viene pero con
mucha fuerza
los niños que tenemos ahora en
preescolar cuatro o cinco años cuando se
gradúen en 10-12 años seguramente ya van
a tener que lidiar con los robots y con
la inteligencia artificial
pero afortunadamente habrá algo que esas
máquinas no les enseñen y que si les
podemos enseñar los padres y los
maestros esto es saber amar saber
perdonar ser solidarios ser empáticos
eso sí podemos enseñarle tenemos que
estar atentos a su comportamiento
tenemos que hacerles ver que si sus
bromas les hacen daño a sus compañeros
ya no son graciosas debemos estar
atentos a lo que hacen porque de pronto
lo que para unos es un simple juego de
niños para otros podría ser un auténtico
infierno por eso es la empatía el
recurso más importante porque a través
de la empatía nosotros conectamos con
los otros con nuestros pares y
conectamos también con la naturaleza por
eso el reto en las aulas ya no es dar
una respuesta la respuesta la
encontramos con un clic donde sea hoy en
día el reto en las aulas es resolver
problemas es sintonizar
es dosificar aquellas emociones
negativas es armonizar diferencias y
respetar las opiniones de mis compañeros
imaginémonos una clase de ciencias
naturales con el tema ecología en donde
el maestro en vez de recitar de memoria
el concepto de ecología enumerar las
características dictar los componentes
pone un vídeo corto a sus estudiantes en
donde se ve que el hombre ensucia los
mares y producto de esto las especies
marinas enferman al final de la clase
termina abre el foro y hace preguntas
tales como que viste en el vídeo que
sentiste es cuando el hombre tiraba
basura te bañaría en ese mar sucio que
sentirte es cuando la tortuga no podía
nadar porque estaba enredada en plástico
que sentirte al ver al delfín que le
dirías a ese señor
no creen ustedes que los niños
aprenderán más de esta manera que
recitando de memoria el concepto de
ecología
en una sola clase logro el maestro que
filósofo que opine que crean y sobre
todo que se sensibilicen yo al menos
estoy convencida de que los maestros
debemos lograr que los niños regresen a
casa con más curiosidad que con tareas
cuando la curiosidad se activa el
aprendizaje se vuelve infinito la
educación entonces sin iniciativa que
solamente se centra en el currículum
definitivamente hoy ya queda obsoleta
debemos trabajar en la educación
emocional de los niños porque la
educación no es para hoy la educación es
para mañana
por eso los docentes debemos utilizar el
contenido como un medio pero para lograr
como finalidad competencias y
habilidades emocionales siento ahora una
frase hermosa de mario benedetti que
dicen nos enseñaron desde chicos cómo
estaba constituido el cuerpo humano
cuáles son sus órganos cuáles son sus
función
cuáles son sus huesos dónde están
ubicados pero nunca nos enseñaron de qué
estaba hecha el alma
cuando un pillo que llega al mundo
definitivamente llega con una curiosidad
impresionante es admirable como se
fascina por todo lo que encuentran yo
tengo un sobrino carlitos cuatro años
entró el otro día mi oficina y me veía
que luchaba con el control remoto no
podía aprender el aire acondicionado y
me dice qué haces y oled yo no puedo
aprender el aire y me dice y si tiene
pilas donde bueno un niño de 4 años si
está bien que haga ese razonamiento digo
si tiene pilas carlitos no sé qué es lo
que pasa
revisa el compresor me dice y ahí sí me
quedé en shock que un niño de 4 años me
diga que revise el compresor es más a mí
jamás se me hubiese ocurrido y estoy
seguro que en su escuela no le enseñan
cosas de compresores ni partes del aire
acondicionado en la educación inicial
donde lo habrá escuchado donde lo habrá
visto no lo sé por eso justamente es que
hoy en día
se hace indispensable que les enseñemos
desde muy temprana edad a pensar y
asentir por sí mismos porque así cuando
la vida los lleve de pronto frente a una
situación un poco complicada ellos sepan
cómo actuar que cuando fracase sepan
convertir ese fracaso en algo que lejos
de frustrarlo los potencia porque el
fracaso en sí no es determinante es
determinante lo que hagamos ante él por
eso también debemos enseñar a nuestros
hijos desde muy chicos a escuchar
ustedes se han puesto a pensar que en la
escuela nos enseñan a leer a escribir a
sumar a restar a multiplicar a dividir
pero nos enseñan a escuchar alguna vez
leí que dios cuando creó al hombre le
puso dos oídos y una boca y era para que
escuche más y hable menos
qué bueno sería que en las escuelas a
más de enseñarnos a hablar en muchos
idiomas nos enseñaran por lo menos a
escuchar en uno
en el arte de educar las emociones debe
promover a la infancia con otro enfoque
ya no como la edad de la desprotección y
desde la dependencia sino en le da en la
etapa en donde se construye el futuro de
ese niño y el futuro se construye ahora
por ello la familia nosotros los padres
somos los primeros que tenemos que
educar las emociones de esos niños
aprovechando sus cerebros que están en
pleno desarrollo citó una frase de
napoleón bonaparte aquí que dice la
educación de un niño empieza 20 años de
su nacimiento de su nacimiento con la
educación de sus padres y cuánta verdad
que hay en eso amigos los niños son
grandes limitadores así que nosotros los
adultos los adultos démosles buenas
cosas para imitar
en la san juste mente de sus padres en
el afán de protegerlos de todo que no
sufran que no pierdan realmente hemos
perdido creo que el norte porque nos
excusamos de todo hablamos por ellos
disculpamos por ellos y realmente nos
olvidamos que cuando ellos salgan al
mundo no van a tener a una persona como
nosotros para que los siga protegiendo y
andarán a la deriva creyendo que no son
que no son comprendidos no hacen clic
con las personas sintiéndose víctimas o
peor aún haciéndose en los victimarios
los niños necesitan amor sí y mucho pero
amor con firmeza límites deben reconocer
a la autoridad necesitan escuchar muchos
no necesitan vivir con poco para que
aprecien lo que tiene realmente así
conseguiremos que ellos afronte en la
vida y este mundo que cada vez es más
si ellos lo experimentan desde pequeños
estas situaciones desfavorables sus
emociones no se van a templar y para
terminar mi sencillo consejo abracen a
sus hijos en la mañana díganle que los
aman antes que se vayan a la escuela
llenen su tanque de amor para que
afronten positivamente el día y ese amor
lo reviertan en su entorno muchas
gracias por venir a meternos
[Aplausos]
[Música]